a ver la verdad es que efectivamente al
salir de la reunión dijo de eso pero yo
creo que hay que en honor a la verdad
durante la conversación
lo que ella señaló es primero el estado
colombiano tiene pendiente un conjunto
información que la comisión le pidió el
18 de mayo sobre las distintas relación
a los derechos humanos que estábamos
haciendo denuncias quedó en enviarlos
esa información la comisión a su vez ha
llamado de oficio una audiencia pública
sobre la situación de derechos humanos
en colombia qué va a hacer en junio por
lo por lo tanto lo que nos señaló la
canciller que ella prefería primero
mandarle una información posteriormente
tener esta audiencia pública y en
paralelo evaluar una eventual visita
para posteriormente yo espero que la
visita a cede sea ahora o sea sea
posteriormente pero si la comisión lo
que ha hecho reiterar la importancia de
que sea lo antes posible ahora está
dentro de rogativa del estado colombiano
determinar primero la anuencia en la
anuencia la visita y el plazo
ahora la señora urréjola la cdh tiene
otros mecanismos para ir trabajando en
el terreno verificar estas denuncias de
abusos
si la comisión bueno de manera
permanente hace un monitoreo de la
situación de derechos humanos los
distintos países de la región
nosotros tenemos distintos mecanismos
para poder recibir información por
ejemplo las propias organizaciones de la
sociedad civil organizaciones de
víctimas están permanentemente
enviándonos información de documentación
tanto prevención están al interior de
los países como organizaciones que
trabajan con otras organizaciones más
pequeñas entre otros países también
recibimos información pública de otros
organismos internacionales como también
una coordinación con la oficina de alta
comisionada de naciones unidas y a su
vez también les dimos información a los
estados y a los órganos de control e
instituciones nacionales de derechos
humanos defensores del pueblo lo que
hizo es un mecanismo que nosotros
estamos diciendo permanentemente
respecto a todo los países del
continente obviamente en situaciones de
crisis como la que está viviendo
colombia el mejor mecanismo que tiene la
comisión es hacer una visita de trabajo
para poder verificar en terreno de las
denuncias que estamos
ahora cuál es la recomendación que le
pudiera hacer tanto a las fuerzas de
seguridad que cuestiona que custodian
las marchas y a los manifestantes que
también han cometido actos de violencia
contra las fuerzas del orden
bueno a ver hay un conjunto de
estándares interamericanos en materia de
derecho a la protesta los estándares
interamericanos en primer lugar y me
parece fundamental establecer que el
derecho a la protesta es un derecho
fundamental en una sociedad democrática
el derecho a la libertad de expresión el
derecho reunión el derecho a la
manifestación son derechos fundamentales
a través de los cuales la ciudadanía a
su vez ejerce otros derechos por ejemplo
en la manera de reclamar el derecho al
trabajo el derecho a la salud es decir
en una manera también de visibilizar el
ejercicio de otros derechos y el derecho
a la protesta es fundamental en una
sociedad democrática y dentro de lo
estándar es cierto el derecho a la
protesta establece cierto que no puede
limitarse el derecho a la protesta
simplemente por una razón de orden
público el derecho a la protesta si
puede estar reglamentado y si tiene
límite y ese límite es el uso la
violencia pero el hecho que
manifestantes hagan uso de la violencia
dentro de las protestas no hace que una
manifestación sea por sí misma violenta
y el estado tiene una obligación
fundamental por una
de aislar a los violentistas y esos
violentistas que cometen delitos tendrán
que ser juzgados como corresponde de
acuerdo a las leyes nacionales que a su
vez el estado tiene la obligación de
garantizar que el resto de la población
que se está manifestando pacíficamente
pueda ejercer ese derecho a la violencia
qué pasa cuando hay vandalismo o
personas que hacen uso la violencia con
el pretexto de ejercer su derecho a la
protesta por un lado si están afectando
el derecho de terceros que no están en
las manifestaciones pero a su vez
también están violentando el derecho a
la protesta de quienes están haciendo el
ejercicio pacífico de este derecho por
lo tanto el estado tiene la obligación
de por una parte como le decía yo
separar a los violentistas hacer hacerla
hacer y cierto las denuncias que
correspondan investigar y sancionar como
corresponde y si acaso cometen delito
pero a la vez tiene que establecer las
condiciones básicas para quienes quieren
ejercer su derecho la mente está lo
puedan hacer
antonia gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en france 24 estábamos
conversando con antonia urréjola
comisionada presidenta de la sede h